hello guys I'm Greg Gregory and Greg and
I'm and I'm Kyle I'll say your name
Jesus first time here I want me to feel
very comfortable top trending is a
channel that gets along with me one of
the few where he they have a video
called six most cursed movie sets of all
time six most cursed movie sets of all
time you ready Kyle I'm pumped
are you pumped I'm pumped one of the
most famous movie curses comes from the
sets of the poltergeist films which
reportedly claimed four lives of the
main cast over its many years of filming
was produced by Steven Spielberg we're a
sensation upon their release devil
chilling aftermath of its human losses
produced a terrifying legacy that sent
shockwaves through Hollywood first there
was the brutal murder of actress
Dominick Dunne at the hands of her
boyfriend upon first glance this was a
tragic loss but nothing that pointed to
a movie curse then the consecutive
losses of actor Will Sampson during a
routine operation and the death of
Julianne Beck who succumbed to cancer
finally the curse struck Heather
O'Rourke the protagonist of the series
who was killed after a misdiagnosis from
doctors when she became ill and fell
into cardiac arrest the reason for the
curse it was reported that some of the
props used in the original film or
actually the remains of deceased
individual nodding the permission used
in the dolly by centering the plot of
the film this is as ironic as it is
tragic
well the filmer took was never proposed
to be a horror movie by mine of
high-profile deaths had left in its wake
would serve as a terrifying Wow of
itself
all those guys received is a comedy
about a traveling Eskimo the part was
first offered to a world famous comedian
John Belushi who had just come off the
wildly popular The Blues Brothers he was
reportedly a huge fan of the script and
signed on immediately only to die
drug overdose before the movie could
enter production the film attempted to
move on recasting the part to actor Sam
Kinison problems with funding persisted
but Kinnison remained attached to the
project until he was killed in a car
accident in 1992 she's not seeing any
concrete warning signs the movie
continued the topic and attaching
popular comedian John Candy just a few
short months later before the movie
could start filming Andy died of a
sudden heart attack production ceased
and the script floated around Hollywood
for almost three years with interest in
the movie waning until it found itself
in the hands of actor and comedian Chris
Farley before he could commit to the
picture Farley died of a drug overdose
and it took was shelf for good terabytes
and black James Wong's conjuring less of
them could be worldwide smashes hell
yeah often sequels that continued to
make money to this day but yeah movies
are full of well-crafted scares the cast
and crew of the first movie experience
strange paranormal events during filming
the audiences include the directors dog
continuously barking at and growling at
a person that was not in the room
the dog's eyes then seemingly watched
something walk from one side of the room
to the other and eventually leave later
actress Vera Farmiga reported seeing
devilish claw markings on the computer
screen she attempted to read the script
she believed at first it was a joke
being played on her by the crew but no
one ever admitted to the brain when the
real-life mother the film was telling
the story a visited percent she said she
felt the same presence of the witch
known as Bathsheba all around the clue
ha she later fell on set and had to be
taken to the hospital and finally
whenever the screenwriters attempted to
call the real-life paranormal
investigator Lorraine Warren that Vera
Farmiga plays in the film their calls
were plagued by static and the line
continuously going dead warned flame
that was unusual
or landline among the most I love that
movie
favorites began the news actor Keanu for
his first child with his been girlfriend
Jennifer sign was stillborn
while filming The Matrix equal sign
herself was killed in a tragic car
accident then his filming got underway
actress and singer alia was killed in a
plane accident she was a wreck as to Z
and the part eventually went to Noma gay
later
actress Gloria foster who played the
Oracle past infidelities at the age of
67 throughout Phil Nanna really suffered
multiple injuries some very serious and
his sister relapsed into a struggle with
leukemia
though she eventually recovered the
similar horror film
Rosemary's on a flat skin on a string of
atrocities that followed filming due to
a reported movie curse the strangest
events noted are that of the death of
the movie's composer who passed away
after a blood clot developed in his
brain
strangely enough his death directly
mirrored that of the characters in the
movie the film's producers suddenly
experienced kidney failure out of
nowhere and had to be rushed into
surgery but perhaps the most horrifying
connection was that of the murder of
Polanski's wife and unborn child by cult
leader Charles Manson Polanski purchased
a house in 1969 for music producer Terry
Melcher who years prior rejected
Manson's propositions to be a musician
in revenge
Manson ordered his cult to invade
melters home and murder everyone inside
what Manson didn't know was that Meltzer
had moved out of the house and Polanski
had moved in while Polanski was not home
that evening Manson's cult brutally
slaughtered six people in one of the
most famous murder cases in American
history but perhaps no movie curse was
as deadly as that of the film The Omen
Kumar's a suit of debts and strange
occurrences plagued the film's
production and leave behind a legacy far
scarier than the movie itself to start
on three separate occasions were people
who were involved with the film getting
struck by lightning while on a plane
screenwriter David Seltzer actor Gregory
Peck and producer mace new fields all
reported surviving freak lightning
storms while filming
later my son would kill himself with
seemingly no warning then an assistant
of a special-effects consultant was
brutally killed in a car accident with
John Richardson to make the curse even
more real when Richardson escaped from
the accident relatively unharmed he
looked up to find a road sign that read
Allman 66 [ __ ] shudders finally a
plane that was originally supposed to be
used in the movie was switched out at
the last moment and redirected for
commercial use it later crashed and
killed all the civilians on board
solidifying the omen as the film with
the most indirect casualties of all time
whoa that was pretty scary the omen what
yeah I don't know if I believe that
whole sign thing like what that's a
little ridiculous and some of these
things are like they are clearly milking
it some of them though that sound I am
crazy I am super like I've always
wondered that about some of these movies
because I I'm very kind of into this
stuff growing up Catholic and everything
we're just very each that's um you never
know like I'm like when you mess around
with this stuff even like story wise it
can get you're inviting stuff in I grew
up Catholic as well oh so what I hear
stuff of like demonic things happening
like it's weird I don't consider myself
someone who believes in you know certain
things of Catholicism anymore it's just
certain things yeah a lot of it however
there's a lot of good I see in it that
being said sorry I hear it's scary [ __ ]
like this and I immediately think might
be true despite the fact that I no
longer conform look at those yeah you
don't want to tempt fate or maybe energy
somehow created this thing yeah yeah
that's pretty soon that I believe in
dark Energy's existing at least you're
allowed to believe whatever you want not
true not when Trump's president I really
feel bad for the little girl
I'm poultry I know I was like oh that's
rough that's I mean so many people died
making that film it's really scary when
you like that makes me not kind of want
to work on certain horror films these
are like demonic things happening you
know things would well and I was just
gonna say like you know the thing that
other than the matrix the thing that
they all had in common was either some
kind of demons or ghosts roar true
well the matrix you know that is some
type of spiritual film in a lot of ways
and it could be you know if you look
into the Matrix Reloaded there's there's
actually a vampires no werewolves in it
here in remember when Monica Bellucci
has has the in the Matrix Reloaded yes
and then she's in that room when she
shoots those two guys in the head yeah
she and she says make some comment about
silver bullets oh yeah they're even
watching like they're laughing at some
like old wolf move oh yeah yeah yeah and
they're applying that and then the
Oracle's talking with her earlier she's
talking about how people believe they
see ghosts vampires werewolves so these
are all you know things that are created
so they do acknowledge that in the
matrix world makes sense makes sense
that I figured it out I am the great
detective right there oh yeah the whole
idea though with poltergeist using real
dead by just don't buy that for a second
there's no way so like yeah yarn
illegally yes I feel like there's a lot
of of hoops they'd have to go over and
even if it did they like borrowing from
Museum like over like we have to get
real corpses yeah oh yeah all of those
guys all the comedian's dying oh my gosh
yeah and that is crazy I wonder if it oh
yeah we're gonna have something to do
with the actual script this is not
considered a horror film a they said
that has this film been released I don't
think so that's an actually an
interesting question I've never even
heard of it
film the American film Wow they just
decided to never make it
yeah people and Hollywood must have
really thought this story was Kirsten
something I mean the thing though it's
like that age of like the of the
comedians these were like the really
overweight unhelpful yeah easy baby you
were gonna meet zoom died of a drug yes
I want another one died of a heart
attack
these guys were people who did not
really take care of themselves now and
and they kept casting those there right
they had a specific type of guy they
were looking for yeah no I'm not saying
like it's okay what happened I'm just
saying they should I don't think it's a
curse the conjuring though I can believe
that [ __ ] because I know they shot it
like real locations for that film no why
would you do that I don't know I think
it's schools I want this movie to be I
don't like I don't want to be involved
in the reality yeah I mean it like
there's something there's something cool
as an actor for you to be like oh I want
to really get engrossed and feel like
I'm really in that world but at some
point you're just messing with elements
yeah I feel like the energies are drawn
to people who usually might believe in
something like this possibly happen yeah
like I feel like I'm the kind of guy to
walk into a conjuring room on set and
bam crazy ass demon [ __ ] comes my way
because I'm like I [ __ ] knew you
people were real on that kind of yeah
yeah it's like believing in fairies or
something
yeah you believe in it and it becomes
real the devil marks on beer for Megas
Pierce who I would scare the [ __ ] out of
me if someone was doing that to my
laptop I find out who was doing and III
not sue them I know it was James Wan
bucks around outside that's to take his
actors seriously love that guy lorraine
warren she said I didn't know she like
passed out on set because she was said
she was experiencing something no I
believe it I mean the whole landline
things is [ __ ] like ridiculous yeah
like the fact that really and to top it
off yeah
like static anytime there's something
they got it lets through that yeah and
it's it's tech I mean things yeah
the matrix yeah man where's Jana donor a
big reason why I like that he was able
to come back with John wick yeah it was
because that that's a character who
experiences a lot of loss and and hiding
from that and I think I feel like that's
more relatable for him than let's say
when he was neo even though he was great
as neo I feel like that was I think he
pushed for John wick to happen because
of that very reason yeah I bet they get
identified perfect for them yeah he
[ __ ] nailed that role dude yeah yeah
yeah so I'm not saying it was good that
it happened I'm just I'm just saying
that he has a terrible loss
I can't imagine I'm like having it just
like still suck it up and like keep on
filming and yeah come on man be
professional yeah I know Leah died her
last movie was Queen of the Damned oh I
saw that it's not good yeah she wasn't
Romeo Must Die with Jett slay which was
cool alright she and the Oracle change
in the matrix yeah at least like how in
the Matrix Revolutions they tried to
justify how they look how why they look
different yes sort of yeah I am fully
justified yeah it was pretty obvious but
they alluded that there was probably a
reason
oh man the Manson murders I don't even
need to like comment it's just it's just
universally no and that is not a good
day I don't really feel like it's a
cursed movie whatever this is I think
Rosemary's Baby I mean I think more than
in a person died of a blood clot similar
to the death of someone the character in
the film come on man convenience the
whole like Manson murders yeah oh my god
they creep me out more than anything and
I mean that's like real people just
murdering slaughtering now it's
something else huh I've seen like
documentaries I've seen them yeah we
really I hear those stories in the whole
street that it took place on Cielo Drive
out here is like super like haunted
I like people hear things see things I
kind of want to check it out
but then again them tempting fate again
so the oh man Danny no Gregory pecks
[ __ ] son killed himself it looks like
his son was so young and then the guy
dying on route 666 yeah dude I believe
that really happened that really
happened there you ain't gonna make that
up
uu is there really a route 666
apparently I think it is sixty six point
six or six point six six something's
fair deal that's a weird road you looked
up to find a road sign that read Allman
66.6 oh yeah okay that's still though it
was the devil devil shows himself in
many ways I'm very superstitious if I
buy something I see those numbers come
up I'm like Oh buy something else I just
don't want to end up on that you see the
people will try to fight the devil but
truthfully the only way to fight evil is
with love it's true love the devil kids
what and that is terrifying that thing
with the planes how they switch them out
that one they switch they can actually
let oh my god I can't believe crash
that's insane
I can't imagine that dying in a plane
crash that's why we need people like
Denzel Washington a flight or Tom Hanks
and Sully your last words big um why
don't you put parachutes on here even
though it wouldn't make a difference I
just there's that hope but just knowing
there's a parachute under my seat and I
could just strap it on and be like we
broke the seal let's all fly out now we
can hopefully open it up oh yeah that's
sure crashed or death if you're in a
plane and it's going down there's
nothing to unfortunately yeah I don't
know three swords people actually
surviving playing freshers no it doesn't
happen
I don't think it's ever happened well
people I'm going to Europe at the end of
September going to Switzerland
Zurich Film Festival so awesome to see
if the plane makes it that's terrible
yeah yeah I'm not gonna work that's
awful
what is your call the plane will make
something happens I'm just like you know
break into his his place here and you
know just take over my cat's I just take
over this take all you add it to my to
my amazing Twitter apparently what were
your last words be Kyle's right why are
there any parachutes underneath my seat
alright guys subscribe your top training
their a worthwhile channel they'll make
your trends even better my name is Greg
this is the real a not done with the
outro this is the real rejects subscribe
today House on Twitter and periscope and
he's in my acting class yes we played uh
Jeremy Renner and Ben Affleck from the
town yeah sorry can totally see you
after watching this